all right yeah uh thanks a lot for
having me here I'm very happy to talk to
you about uh an infrastructure that we
have just set up at cestro and in my
presentation I wanted to show you a
little bit of yeah what we did um and
what is a good practice from our
perspective if you want to integrate the
professional posit products into your
infrastructure just just before you we
start let's let me give you um the
opportunity to um introduce me um
quickly so I belong to a company called
aota we were founded in 2010 and we do
data science from the very beginning on
we are about 50 employees at the moment
and we are located in Germany pretty
much in the center of Germany not too
far away from the geographical center of
the EU um and we are posit partner since
2017 and our vision is empowering
datadriven intelligence and that is
pretty much in line I think what the
mission of posit
is so we have four pillars of what we do
so we have consulting services use case
workshops um proof of concept projects
and in implementation of algorithms into
um productive environments we have
trainings we have infrastructure and we
have data science software and today um
I want will focus on the pillar of data
science infrastructure this is what we
call when we kind of help companies that
have an internal larger group of data
scientists um which want to use
professional
products and uh yeah as the situation is
a little bit complicated I also want to
introduce our customer uh it's a company
called cestro which is also located in
Germany um it's quite big 880,000
employees 50 production sites all around
the globe and the headquarter in Germany
um and what they do is is they create
polymeres and you know High
sophisticated and high performance
plastic components that you will use in
everyday life uh so probably almost
everybody of you have used some sort of
product from
cestro and uh the situation where we
have started was that uh there was
already an existing data science team so
covestro does data science since I don't
know 100 years or so because you know
they do chemical trials and experiments
and stuff like that so they they are
yeah kind of a data science um Centric
company from the very beginning on um
and they they wanted they just wanted to
bring their infrastructure and their way
of how to do data science on the next
level so this is uh how we came in and I
think this is important because the
situation is probably a bit different if
uh data science is more or less newly
introduced to a company or if there's
already an existing team that does
something and wants to mature to the
next
level all right so the general challenge
when it comes to um building up a
centralized data science infrastructure
uh we heard this also in the in the
keynote speeches uh is that there are
two perspective on how it feels like to
be a captain of your ship so the it
operation perspective is pretty much uh
like that so you have a pretty big ship
you want to drive it over the Atlantic
Ocean for example uh once the course is
set you don't want to make any changes
anymore so and if nothing happens then
you had a good day because you know you
are good uh well now it's a little bit
over the top but to make the point a
little bit clear
clearer uh as a data scientist it feels
a little bit more like this to be
captain of your ship you know you want
to have a um yeah a powerful motor
um you want to be able to change your
direction quickly and in most cases you
don't you are not so far away from the
shoreline you typically wouldn't cross
uh the ocean with such a boat um but
this is kind of the way it works and
there are also other perspectives
business uh perspectives or data
governance perspectives which are pretty
much yeah somewhere in the middle of
these and so one of the key challenges
from my perspective is to bring those
two perspectives together it's not
either this or that both perspectives
are are valid and um when uh so so those
implementation projects are typically
successful if both sides have a mutual
understanding of the other
side and this is generally speaking not
particular for cesto I
say well um at covestro we did it in a
three-step way this is actually our good
practice of how to introduce centralized
data science infrastructures so the
first step is an assessment step um
where we try to find out okay where
where where are you what's what's your
position at the moment so what are the
databases that you could never get rid
of for example and what are the
Technologies where you say well they are
somewhat um they're not up to date
anymore and uh it might be possible to
migrate so um and we also want to know
like where are you now and terms of data
science use cases and where are you
seeing yourself in the foreseeable
future like in the next two three three
years or
so and yeah one of the central aspects
of those assessments is to bring all the
perspectives the business perspective
the data governance perspective the it
operation perspective and the data
science perspective all together and uh
this is really important to have um like
from every stakeholder group somebody on
the table all at once right so that
there's a common understanding where we
want to go and how we how to do it the
next step is the implementation itself
it means like just setting up the
infrastructure what we have just decided
for and uh it's yeah the implementation
step from our from our point of view is
really like you would do it in a data
science project you think of iterations
you start with a minimal viable product
uh where somebody can use it and when
you can where you can gain uh you know
the experiences uh from the users from
the data scientists in order to proove
uh to improve um the infrastructure and
finally there's the operation side so
once everything is in place and you know
the business and data science people are
kind of running crucial apps um on this
infrastructure it needs to be operated
and then there's like uh step forth step
back yeah it's like def Ops idea
Implement and operate and more or less
at the same
time
so um after we finished the assessment
with cestro we had like a list of
challenges they faced with their
existing infrastructure or with the
existing way of how they do data science
and we had a list of goals where um
where they wanted to
go so the challenges were like there
were 20 to 30 um on python developers
well that's not the challenge in itself
but they were distributed across uh
multiple locations and multiple dis um
um business lines so there was actually
something like an internal Meetup of the
data scientists who like exchange what
they do but it was not really the case
that they feel like you know a common
group they were more or less splitted um
in their
departments the data science uh
infrastructure itself was pretty much
decentralized so well they had some you
know kind of advanced workflows with
basically everybody was working on his
or her
laptop uh so um this was kind of the
original situation and they expected a
substantial growth in data and I guess
this is what every organization can say
that there is a substantial growth uh in
data from the it operation side that was
a quite High administrative overhead you
know to set up all those images of R and
all the packages and um it was also not
so easy to tackle the compliance issues
that you have in a larger organization
they kind of they managed to do it but
it just took a bit too much time to do
it and they look were looking for
something which makes it easier for
them yeah and of course like always if
you work in decentralized um
infrastructure they had issues with um
compatibility you know ver version
dependencies and you know all those the
things which you might all know and uh
this is one aspect of a centralized
infrastructure that you can really get
rid of this
stuff these are the challenges like the
main challenges they face and on the
other hand um we have we have goals so
what do they want they want to be able
to collaborate they want to be able to
share um projects and results they want
to have Central um package management so
that it's easy to kind of exchange the
packages and to to get always the same
version that all the others
have um they were looking for efficiency
so they want to reduce um yeah the
efforts of the admin people um and they
want in consistent data governance I'm
not talking too much about the
governance issue but this is also
important not only the infrastructure
also the the data governance is
important and this was on their list of
goals um yeah because of the growth they
were expecting and all the new
technology that's coming up all the time
they were they wanted to be able to
scale out horizontally and
vertically um but they still wanted to
have everything
secure of course um and they want an
easy development pipeline so it is easy
to develop something and to bring it to
the business user as easy as
possible yeah so and um what we did then
is we set up an
infrastructure um which is your you know
posit Centric infrastructure if you will
and in the next couple of slides well
it's actually just one slide I will uh
show you how this infrastructure looked
like a little bit more into detail not
all the details but uh I hope you can
you can get an idea how it looked like
and it might help you um to do the same
in your
organization so first of all we have set
it up um a posit workbench um on um AWS
and this is what the developers were
using from the beginning on and the cool
thing is if you switch from laptop to a
centralized posit workbench on AWS it's
not not not much different for for from
the user experience and that's really
really important for the acceptance yeah
so um there's especially one user who is
kind of um I don't know he works with r
for 25 years or so he's really good
really really good and he was like okay
I have to have everything on my laptop
this is the only way it will work for me
so I cannot believe that it's possible
uh if we have an infrastructure on the
cloud and finally after we finished
everything he would not want to work
every time in his his life again on his
laptop so that was our greatest success
indicator
actually yeah so um then we kind of
combined the workbench with an Azure
active directory and we use summer to to
do the um communication between um pule
and and um the active directory and the
interesting thing here is and we see
this in many many organizations
actually they um mix the cloud providers
so the the operation platform is
AWS but the platform that provided the
active directory is azure in this
case and um when we started the
implementation we actually had sessions
that worked on the server but it was
clear from the beginning on that we
going to switch to um kubernetes setup
where the sessions are kind of Spawn
into a cubinator
cluster and the way we did it here is um
like an offhost execution that means
that the posit workbench server is not
in kubernetes only the sessions are
running in kubernetes and that worked
out pretty well and we distinguish
between kind of three load groups
you know we had um a low a medium and
high load um that means of the computer
power that the applications or the
computation needs and that was really
useful in order to you know provide the
respective resources to the
users and additionally we had an NFS
share um so that's an external file uh
share where the users had the home um
directories on and that is uh also a
good practice from our perspective to
have this on a separated server whenever
there's an issue on the posit server on
the workbench server then you have the
separated and you can you can just you
have no issues in updating
anything yeah next step was to um set up
a posit connect in a in a death
environment um development environment
this is how we started and um the
developer were able to push um what they
have done as apis or as shiny apps or
reports to this connect server and they
were also consumers of this connect
server so it's not only that they kind
of provided stuff to the business people
but it's also the case that they used it
theel and make their life much easier to
have a central reliable uh you know base
where um the data and the analytics are
kind of um to be found and it's easy to
uh and to be be sure that everything is
in one
place so the developers actually are
heavy users of the connector
themselves yeah same idea is we kind of
um externalized uh the app directories
on an uh NFS share and um there's an
it's probably a detail but uh very
helpful there's a post CB within connect
and we kind of externalize this too uh
this has two advantages the first is you
can do update on the connect server
while it's running and whenever you have
to set up your connect server again
everything is kind of in on a separate
server so that worked out pretty well
and then same thing um with uh the
production environment so it's basically
two types of server so it's a a two-tier
environment if you will so development
plus test and um a production
environment and and now for other for
other customers we have a three tier
where we kind of distinguish between
development and test but in this case it
was okay uh to just go with one
development server and the production
environment and uh where the business
users um you know in this on the other
end of of the diagram in in in the
infrastructure perspective at least they
were heavily they are heavily using the
apis um or mainly the shiny apps that
were provided uh from the Developers so
that's kind of cool and finally we added
um uh the package uh manager on top of
that um as an external thing and um also
uh externalized um the packages
themselves and the the metadata of those
packages so this is more or less the
infrastructure how it looks like um
there are some components missing there
was also git there was also continuous
integration there not everything on the
table and there are also other
perspectives which are quite important
um when you introduce something like
this and this is for example like how
the data flows the data governance
perspective um I was not talking about
that and also the use case perspective
so how do you manage use cases so if a
business user comes up and say okay I
have this and that use case and that
would be pretty cool if I have this
somebody has to
evaluate uh what is important and
prioritize what is important what's not
important um because it will not take
long until you have so many demand from
the business us users that you are not
able to serve everything and this is
another perspective that I have not here
on this this
slide yeah so to summarize U what I just
said um what were the
advantages so it is easy to collaborate
um for U the data scientists across
departments also to communicate between
data scientists and business users so
the agility of data science was also
introduced into other parts of the
organization just what we heard um in
the in the keynote speech before um
that's an interesting aspect if data
science agility mindset goes into the
organization that is good for the
organization as well the maintainability
was improved and that was good from the
perspective of the it operators so they
were really happy so that they it's much
easier for them to manage everything the
performance was increased and it was
much U more
flexible um ah yeah one thing I forgot
to mention I know sorry I will mention
later so um okay just forgot about it so
and and it was uh another Advantage is
that it is in line with compliance
guidelines I mean they they um they were
before of course in line with compliance
guidelines but this infrastructure is
also uh compliant and that is of course
a very important aspect so what I wanted
to say a minute ago was avoid manual
steps from the beginning on something
that I haven't mentioned yet we did this
uh from the very beginning on with
infrastructure as code and terraform in
this example and that's pretty cool
because if you want to roll out the same
environment you know in the Asia and
Pacific region for example it's just one
click um very easy and we have other use
cases for example where we kind of set
up a training environment just for a
couple of days and if you do it in
terraform this is really easy to do so
this is really our kind of learning
there that uh we always build
infrastructure with terraform or or
similar
tools um so the question of cloud versus
on Prem versus hybrid uh infrastructure
that is at least um in Germany very
violent so many companies still not kind
of completely going into the cloud
everything I've just showed it although
it was um created in the cloud it's
possible to do this on Prem as well and
um Al so with a cuberes cluster you can
run a cubet cluster on Prem I don't know
if I would want to do it but it's
possible um so it's always good to
develop the infrastructure in close
coordination with data science also with
the business users that is our kind of
Lessons Learned and the implementation
in iterations really makes sense so
don't do everything at once what's your
um Lookout what is your minimal viable
product implement this and have it used
and then you get feedback by the
users all right yeah and that that's
everything uh I'd have to say thank you
for your attention uh you find my
contact details here so if you are
interested in uh to chat about some more
details I'm happy to to talk with
[Applause]
you